foreign
[Music]
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just hard to see my little man not
being my little boy all the time
yeah
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to go on to the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you miles
it was they won't look out for you like
us
miles
wanna get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from
[Music]
and he never doubts that he is loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
who do you think you are really
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
[Music]
foreign